the harry potter franchise has gone from
one of the most lucrative investments in
the entertainment industry to a major
headache for warner brothers
it all started when the studio decided
to move full steam ahead on a prequel
series beginning with fantastic beasts
and where to find them
this involved casting johnny depp as the
dark wizard grindelwald a decision that
was met with derision from fans after
allegations came out claiming depp
physically assaulted his former wife
amber hurd
no doubt this controversy combined with
incredibly poor reviews led to a
significant drop in box office revenue
and the sequel fantastic beasts and the
crimes of grindelwald rose just over 650
million dollars worldwide
roger ebert never got a crack at
reviewing it but if he had his reaction
might have been something like this
this movie is a total disappointment no
thought went into it no effort went into
it
well there are still plans to make a
third film in the series warner brothers
has decided to let depp go from his role
of grindelwald
this comes in the aftermath of depp and
his attorneys filing a libel lawsuit
against news group newspapers in july of
2020.
the lawsuit stemmed from the news source
referring to depp as a wife beater but
depp was dealt a blow and the court
ruled against him on november 2nd
a few days after the court rendered its
decision depp took to instagram to post
notice to his fans that while he'll
continue fighting his case and appealing
the court's decision he'll be stepping
down from the fantastic beasts franchise
a decision that appears to accord with
the studio's wishes perhaps surprisingly
one person who's staying away from this
conversation
at least for the time being appears to
be harry potter creator and writer for
the fantastic beasts movies jk rowling
jk rowling has long been in depth's
corner in terms of keeping him in her
movies
back when he was first cast as
grindelwald rowling released a statement
making her support for the actor clear
she wrote how she understood how some
fans may have trepidation about depth
coming into the franchise but she also
claimed
for me personally the inability to speak
openly to fans about this issue has been
difficult frustrating and at times
painful
however the agreements that have been
put in place to protect the privacy of
two people
both of whom have expressed the desire
to get on with their lives must be
respected
based on our understanding of the
circumstances the filmmakers and i are
not only comfortable sticking with our
original casting
but genuinely happy to have johnny
playing a major character in the movies
however it appears as though this time
around rowling didn't push warner
brothers to keep deaf after he lost his
most recent lawsuit against news group
newspapers
according to a report from the hollywood
reporter a source claims that rowling
didn't fight to keep depp in the movie
which is significant
considering the amount of influence she
likely has at warner brothers
harry potter continues to be a major
cash cow for the studio so undoubtedly
if rowling wanted to keep death
there is a good chance warner brothers
would have at least heard her out it's
also possible rowling herself is trying
to do a bit of damage control
considering the amount of pushback she's
received over the last year due to
comments she's made over twitter that
many consider to be insensitive and
transphobic
eddie redmayne who plays newt scamander
in the fantastic b series has denounced
her comments
and other former harry potter stars such
as daniel radcliffe and emma watson have
also gone on the record to say they
don't approve of what rowling has said
about the transgender community
there is also the matter of ezra miller
who plays credence fairbone in the
fantastic b
series earlier this year a video
surfaced of miller choking and slamming
a female fan to the ground which
prompted a slew of petitions to see them
removed from future fantastic beasts
movies as well as the upcoming flash
film
as of this writing miller is still
expected to reprise their role in
fantastic
beasts 3 but considering warner brothers
was okay with letting depth go after
they had already started filming
anything could happen going forward
the hollywood reporter states that
fantastic beasts 3 has been pushed back
yet again for a july 15
2022 release date there's no word yet on
who will replace depp as grindelwald if
they decide to recast at all so keep
checking back for updates as this behind
the scenes turmoil continues to unfold
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie
franchises are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one